[Music]
there are those
who look into the eyes of another and
see
opportunity a soul
to corrupt and twist
their stories are the ones we fear
and there are those who see potential
the light within the soul
a chance to lift someone up to achieve
the impossible
[Music]
their stories rise to legend
so tell me
[Music]
what do you see in quill
[Music]
because her story depends
on you
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for kicking off our new state of
play quill
moss 2 is currently in development for
psvr
we've got some more exciting updates
today so let's keep it going
here's a flashy new multiplayer shooter
from the team at illfonic
[Music]
now
[Music]
just
[Music]
[Music]
that was your first look at arcata gedit
which begins early access today for
playstation 5.
tribes of midgard arrives later this
month let's get a sneak peek at the post
launch plans for this addictive action
rpg from norse fell games
hi i'm sydney from norseville and i'm
here to tell you more about how tribes
of midgard will grow even bigger after
launch with free season updates
tribes of midgard is a 10 player
survival action rpg
where you play as an inheriar a
legendary viking warrior revived by odin
himself to stop
ragnarok there are two primary game
modes the session based saga mode
and the endless survival mode that are
all about exploring midgard
powering up your character and
fortifying your home village
to stand against giants bend on
destroying the seat of yggdrasil
new seasonal updates will change the way
you play and add challenges for you and
your tribe to overcome
the game launches with season 1 the wolf
saga it includes new classes
exclusive loot and a powerful new boss
there will be eight different classes to
unlock and choose from
let's take a quick look at the ranger
one of our two starting classes
as you gain levels you unlock game
changing abilities in your class skill
tree to match your play style
like the lightning fast quick shot or
the powerful slow poke
because classes are complementary it's
fun to have a bit of everything in your
try
we're excited to see how your strategies
will change as classes expand
in future updates
[Music]
season one also introduces runes which
give you new special powers to customize
your character
even more the wolf sega will launch with
30 runes
including the might of mjolnir which
adds powerful chain lightning arcs to
your taps
you can use multiple runes together and
the effects can get pretty wild
you'll end up with different rune
combinations each session so you'll
always have new ways to experiment
last but not least the biggest part of
every season are saga quests a series of
quests that will bring you across
midgard
in season one saga you'll unlock the
ability to access a mysterious lair and
face down your most
powerful challenge yet and the more
dangerous foes you take on
the greater the reward speaking of great
rewards the wolf sega is stacked with
season exclusive weapons armor sets
and truly mighty companions i love this
guy
this saga is only the beginning tribes
of midgard will keep expanding with
more seasons that explore different
parts of norse mythology and add even
more to the game
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
midgard soon on july 27th
[Music]
port cities as good as lost
must you go back i must go back
in order to end all this
now
you shall now witness the true power of
the spark rages
up next what do you get when you mix
fighting games and battle royale
ancient legends are told
[Music]
of the battle between demons and hunters
[Music]
hi everyone i'm john georgie from
mantisco
and on behalf of our studio i am
thrilled to welcome you to the world of
hunters arena
[Music]
in this mystical world you will play as
hunters who must fight deadly demons as
well as other online players in order to
survive
as a skillful hunter you will master
powerful swordplay and martial arts
and will be constantly tested of your
skills of precise timing and fast
decision making
however don't forget to have a little
fun on your journey by customizing your
weapons from disco balls to rubber ducks
as you explore our expansive maps you
will be able to explore dungeons and
slay ancient demons to level up
we look forward to seeing your
personalized strategies on your hunt
another huge threat to look out for is
none other than one of your own
a hunter always have different
strategies in mind
and use the environment around you when
facing your enemies
utilize bushes for ambush or drop strike
from higher grounds to unleash a lethal
blow on
unexpecting enemy players
hunters arena features two battle royale
modes solo and trio
in solo mode you will solely take on
other enemy players as well as deadly
demons lurking behind your back in a 30
player free-for-all
in trio mode you'll be able to team up
with your friends where focusing on
teamwork and planning out strategies
are crucial in achieving victory
there is so much more to experience in
this fascinating world
i can't wait for you to encounter the
countless dangers
waiting in hunters arena when it
launches next month
on ps4 and ps5
thank you for joining me today and i
will see you all soon
on hunters arena
jump into battle royale action when
hunters arena legends arrives on ps4 and
ps5 next month
playstation plus members will be able to
download the ps4 and ps5 versions at no
extra cost
starting august 3rd
oh
oh
oh
so
[Music]
ever wanted to explore an alien planet
then this next game is for you
[Music]
this is jet the far shore created by
super brothers and pine scented
with a score by scientific
in chat you play as may one of a unit of
aviator scientists
who embark on an interstellar trip and a
light on a mythic
ocean planet where they dream of
securing a future
for their species we
aspired to create a video game to
express our own
feelings of awe when we look up at the
starry sky
[Music]
jet is all about motion whether it's
weaving through trees
or jumping over obstacles
i love that sense of speeding through a
remarkable natural space under a grand
sky
and suddenly being in someone's helmet
boots on the ground
jet's premise involves exploration and
discovery
however our design doesn't rely on
combat or
resource extraction and the characters
go to some lengths
to tread lightly giving indigenous
wildlife
a wide berth striving to adapt
and avoid conflict as a jet scout you'll
inspect living things and employ your
jets tools to figure out
what makes them tick occasionally you'll
run into trouble
and you'll have to use everything at
your disposal to emerge unscathed
[Music]
over the years we've contemplated what
might be on the minds of interstellar
explorers
what might propel them and what might
haunt them
and so our story provides an occasional
glimpse into may's dreams
memories and visions
at heart jet is a laid-back
and enjoyable exploratory action
adventure
set within an intriguing new science
fiction cosmos
jet has had a long road for a few years
there were only three of us
since then this vision has been
sharpened
and bolstered by an all-star squad
we hope you'll embark with us
[Music]
let's check in with our friends at sega
for more on two upcoming adventures
[Music]
[Music]
a mansion is this the place
i'm scared it's okay i'm with you
i'll keep you safe
the demon sent us growing stronger
the door it just closed on its own you
saw it right
i don't care who just come and fight me
whoever shows up will be my next play
i'm a demon slayer rank mizunoto tanjiro
commodore
and he's wielding naturine swords is he
with the demon slayer core
senitsu
he's not just pretending he's really out
cold
[Music]
thunder breathing first form thunderclap
and flash
it's gonna feel so good to rip such a
huge target to shreds
how could this human wound me
let's go i'm not giving up not ever
keep moving forward stay sharp give it
everything you've got
you can do it i'll get my hands on that
rare blood and reclaim my rightful place
among the 12
kizuki yes i've got him now
[Music]
your honor
in the warehouse about three days ago
a body turned up in yokohama oh
maybe you hadn't heard that
you mean it's revenge in that case
could he possibly have hired someone
else to kill the guy in his stead
as for my request i'd like to see what
you can find out
mikoshiba's murder is too suspicious
[Music]
suspicious
[Music]
i believe in you buddy
watch believe me i'm just as clueless as
you are
much as i hate to admit it
[Music]
they said to tell you this is your final
warning
they've been spying on me i guess we
couldn't ask for a better piece of bait
what the hell do you think you're doing
this has nothing to do with her
stop come on
[Music]
wow
our next game was revealed just a few
weeks ago time for a closer look at the
expanded and enhanced
death stranding director's cut coming
soon to ps5
[Music]
once there was an explosion
a bang which gave rise to life as we
know it
then came the next explosion an
explosion that will be our last
sam i'll be waiting for you on the beach
rebuilding america isn't gonna get rid
of the bts
but at least we'll have hope
i'm a porter i don't care about
connecting anything
you see i've come to understand the
truth of the death stranding
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
me
[Music]
i'll be waiting for you on the beach
[Music]
[Music]
death loop hits ps5 on september 14th
let's check out an extended gameplay
demo of bethesda and arcane's violent
[Music]
vision
[Music]
[Music]
to kill me it's fun i've been cutting
short your meaningless rampages for some
time
it's totally normal death is a typical
physiological experience in this way
i hate to break it to you but there is
nothing normal about this [ __ ] island
[Music]
you're gonna give me that attitude
same day which means i already know
what's going to happen
am i supposed to do this every day for
the rest of my life
[ __ ] that i'm breaking this loop i'm
dinga
game director at arcane leon and i'm
here to give you a special look
at desloop you are cold
you're stuck in a time loop on the
island of black reef where everybody
wants you dead
to escape you'll have to take out eight
targets known as the visionaries before
the day repeats
also one of your targets juliana is in
the business of hunting you down
fail to kill the target or die
and the day starts over oh you gotta be
kidding me
but every loop is an opportunity with
every cycle you will learn more about
the visionaries and the secrets of the
island by exploring and observing
you will discover their habits and
secrets using that knowledge
to progress through the story let's jump
into a mission
several hours into the game to see colt
take on the visionary
alexis the wolf dorsey at this point you
have already learned from a previous
loop that alexis plans to give a speech
at his well-guarded masquerade party
let's use that intel to identify alexis
and take him down i was just thinking
i want to know what the [ __ ] is going on
oh you don't want that
you're looking for a purpose i'm looking
for the fastest way out of this place
there are rules cult and sometimes
people bend the rules and sometimes
they break them blah blah blah are you
talking when i was talking
i have top secret information okay what
is it
i said it was top secret
okay okay
i've thought about it and uh i think i'm
doing everyone here a favor
by ending this so what happens when you
break the loop seriously i want your
theories
everything goes back to normal obviously
normal
you have absolutely no [ __ ] idea what
will happen
true but i know one way to find out
[Music]
dying isn't the end reprise is one of
the powers you can unlock it allows you
to die and rewind twice
before the loop restarts you have also
seen carnesis
that allows you to yank enemies around
and shifts the short-range teleport
hey we killed you
yourself
here's where colts died you can absorb
your body to regain residium a resource
that allows you to save your favorite
weapons and abilities between loops
over time you will build an arsenal of
weapons abilities and upgrades
that you can mix and match between
missions to suit your playstyle or the
needs of a specific task
[Music]
we use the haptic feedback and the
adaptive trigger of the ps5
dual sense controller to bring an extra
layer of immersion to your experience
every movement feels different and
weapons express their personality in the
palm of your hands impressive i'm
clapping with one hand
don't stop there put them both together
the body count is gonna get high
invitation to alexis's party i found
another way in
through the window no no i'm not
climbing on any cliff
or window just shut up there's always
multiple ways to approach a target
and we just learned of one a back
entrance to the mansion
conversations like this happen all over
black reef and it often pays to stop and
listen
[Music]
like what
that alert means your rival juliana has
invaded your game
controlled by another player or the ai
she's the real deal
you'll have to be extra vigilant when
she's on the hunt
[Music]
you're all business all the time aren't
you what is your style exactly
when i should be killing [ __ ]
[Music]
apparently
[Music]
the wolves play a sick game whoever
fails to impress the others with their
evil deeds
goes into the grinder and onto the
dinner menu
let's see if we can read the outcome
what
[Music]
it could be alexis but it could also be
another masked speaker
so let's hear him out and not take the
shots
lawsuits whatever profits far
outstretched our small legal fees
we made millions that year chief
bastards who died
they could have afforded it arrogant
cruel no regard for others yeah
that's definitely alexis
aliop alexis just dropped an upgrade to
the carnegie's power
and a hefty dose of residue time to get
the hell out of him
what are you doing up there
[Music]
somebody
[Music]
[Music]
you're gonna call me like this all the
time julie julia
but you did once
that's a wrap for today but we'll be
back with more breaking news and updates
before you know it
see you soon
playstation